[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je t'aime tu aimes tu m'avais monter sur
scène bruce m
temarii n'est plus un stade où certes
tu m'as vraiment et elle inclut beige tu
es la plus belle
paris ma tête je rentrais chez moi
bruxelles paris bruxelles à
bruxelles pas
[Musique]
mal à s que le mur est à distance la
distance cela dit
on y va et clin d'oeil comme les ok
c'est parti
qui viennent l'adulte et
[Rires]
julien
bonjour pomme ouais bah ouais tu as la
peau même c'est bon c'est pas de ta mine
à
huy
cette bête
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ba ba ba ba ba comme thiébaut a
comme celle beaux enfants pire
en pire thiébaut warnault a ainsi musclé
[Rires]
la raison du
but